[Musique]
watch et ben je fais comme les clips de
rapetisser je veux voir mon beef
ouais mais les grandes fortunes il
commence comme ça tu vois ils prennent
ça après le plat c'est tout moi j'en ai
moins souvent et c'est beaucoup de sous
ok bonne nouvelle pas besoin d'être
milliardaire pour s'équiper du meilleur
matériel en faisant en plus des
économies et de manière écologique pour
ça il suffit d'utiliser bac market qui
reconditionne des produits en lui
remettant à neuf dans des usines
spécialisées
je vous en reparle un peu plus tard dans
cette vidéo salut aujourd'hui nous
allons donc voir ce qu'on peut appeler
petit craquage des milliardaires quand
nous on dit un euro c'est pas cher pour
eux on peut rajouter trois ou quatre
zéros derrière l'euro ça reste une
baguette de pain mais le but de cette
vidéo c'est pas seulement de voir dans
quel délire d'achat ils sont capables de
se lancer
même si on rit on a envie de savoir dans
quoi fouine est un petit peu mais on a
aussi envie de savoir ce qui se passe
dans le cerveau d'une personne
lorsqu'elle devient aussi riche et
puissant
il ya déjà quelques temps bill gates le
fondateur de microsoft il a craqué sur
un jet comme vous pourriez craquer sur
une petite trottinette électrique
le prix du jet 40 millions d'euros pour
un avion qui peut accueillir que 19
passagers à sa faut rajouter quand même
les frais pour l'équipage l'entretien
l'assurance le carburant à chaque fois
qu'ils s'en servent
bref c'est un peu plus de frais qu'une
clio apparemment mais vous allez me dire
on fait pas le même déplacement en jet
qu'en voiture et vous avez raison donc
pour une meilleure comparaison
dites-vous que bill gate il a trois
porsche 911 une carrera cabriolet 964
1959 coupé de 1988 une jaguar cj si
c'est une petite ferrari 348 mais ça
c'est pour échanger son parc automobile
représente un coût de presque 600 mille
euros et ce qui nous paraît incroyable
c'est que nous on calcule avec nos
seules de référence à nous par rapport à
ce qu'on connaisse convient mais dites
vous que lui il gagne environ 500000
euros par mois en france le salaire
mensuel médian est de 1700 euros par
mois en gros huit bill gates y gagne 300
fois plus que ça quand il a acheté son
jet privé il a dit que c'était je cite
un sa grande folie c'est comme si
quelqu'un qui gagne est le salaire moyen
au médian du moins en france
craquez pour une porsche panamera à
environ 120 130 mille euros 9
c'est ça que ça représente et ce qui est
vraiment intéressant c'est que notre
cerveau est bourré de biais cognitif qui
ne nous permettent pas d'appréhender le
côté fou de la dépense
il faut rationaliser par pourcentage ou
par comparaison d'ailleurs bill gates a
une fortune estimée à environ 100
milliards de dollars
c'est pas dégueu mais sur ce genre de
valeur notre cerveau il rame aussi à les
appréhender parce qu'il sait pas se
représenter un milliard d'objets tu t'es
capable d'imaginer un milliard de
quelque chose devant toi m trop de trop
dur non plus quelle est la différence
entre un million et 1 milliard en termes
de proportion
ça c'est pas simple de le visualiser
mais on peut rationaliser en passant par
des secondes 1 million de seconde
ça représente environ 11 jours à
milliards de secondes ça fait un peu
plus de 30 ans onze jours trente ans du
coup quand bill gate il investit 144
millions de dollars en 2013 pour
participer à l'achat ou au rachat du
ritz-carlton de san francisco en fait
ils dépensent l'équivalent de deux ans
de salaire dans un business c'est comme
si toi loïc tu investis ces 30 à 40000
euros dans une société et du coup en
rationalisant on se rend compte
juste avant de passer au fondateur de
tesla laissez moi vous parler du sponsor
de cette vidéo qui mélange également
tech et argent mais dans un sens qui
nous arrange ce coup ci je vous en avais
déjà parlé sur ma chaîne puisque je suis
vraiment clients chez eux
par exemple j'ai acheté le téléphone de
mon père là bas pour son anniversaire
ce bac market l'idée de bach markets est
simple les reconditionne des téléphones
des ipad des ordinateurs des repose tout
ce que vous avez sûrement 12 ans pour la
rentrée les produits sont remis à neuf
par des spécialistes et revendus jusqu'à
70 % moins cher avec s'il vous plaît une
garantie de 12 mois minimum
au delà de l'économie j'aime l'idée de
qu'on produise pas de nouveaux matériels
et donc de réduire la pollution et le
gaspillage tout en payant moins cher ça
c'est cool
et comme on vient de changer de locaux
et que j'ai recruter de nouvelles
personnes qui vont travailler maintenant
avec nous je vais avoir besoin d'un peu
de matos
déjà je vais avoir besoin d'ordi ça
c'est pas mal ça c'est pas mal pour le
poste d'assistant assistante de
production macbook air 13 pouces un
terme à lille et à 1100 là il à 825
euros ça fait 25 % de réduction
garantie 12 mois aya lui aussi qui est
pas mal du tout il est encore mal à 2200
euros
et là il est à 1549 euros donc en gros
29 % de réduction mille quatre cents
grammes de gâchis électronique ans - va
nous falloir aussi des téléphones iphone
cette fière que pour le bureau c'est
très bien et pas besoin d'avoir le
dernier iphone 32 gigas coûte 770 euros
là on peut le toucher à 174 euros ça
fait 77 % de réduction on est clairement
sur de la bonne affaire
regardez un peu ce qu'ils ont dans les
aspirateurs taïso le roomba
ils l'ont à 279 euros au lieu de 700 60%
de réduction garantie 12 mois 7 kg de
gâcher électronique en moins dernière
chose qui peut intéresser une partie
d'entre vous les étudiants ont le droit
à une réduction de 5% en plus surtout le
site en s'inscrivant gratuitement au
programme étudiants je vous invite à
faire un tour sur bach market en passant
par mon lien qui est dans la description
est en gros je sais pas quoi vous dire
de plus si vous voulez vous équiper je
vois vraiment pas l'intérêt de payer
cher de produire de nouveaux déchets
alors que là vous avez ici la même chose
et je sais je devais déjà dit mais c'est
le garantis cliquez sur le lien en bas
et vous pourrez voir toutes les offres
qu'ils ont à ce moment
vous trouviez que le jet de bill gates
il était cher celui d'elon musk le
fondateur de tesla et des spécifiques
août 62 millions d'euros avion qui lui a
coûté plus d'un million en un an juste
pour ses déplacements
alors là c'est difficile de comparer ce
petit coup de coeur à son salaire
mensuel parce que elon musk comme
beaucoup d'autres il ne se verse qu'un
salaire symbolique et il se fait
rémunérer sur ses performances il a par
exemple touché son premier salaire chez
tesla juste avant cet été
un salaire de 770 millions d'euros on
devrait plutôt dire une plus value de la
capitalisation boursière qui possède
chez tesla
il s'est offert aussi une des voitures
de james bond
la lotus esprit 1976 qui était dans le
film l'espion qui m'aimait donc 89
milles euros pour cette voiture sous
marins évidemment pour ne pas dormir à
la belle étoile c'est une maison en fin
de saison c'est un domaine à 17 millions
d'euros qui s'est offert à los angeles
et new à côté de ça qu'est-ce qu'on peut
s'offrir est bien là par exemple il ya
des choses gratuites que vous pouvez
obtenir tout de suite par exemple un
abonnement à cette chaîne youtube c'est
gratuit c'est juste un petit clic vous
faites un deuxième cliquer sur la petite
cloche pour ne pas rater les prochaines
vidéos
c'est un vrai livre de milliardaire
puisque c'est comme avaler cette cloche
qui vient vous prévenir que de nouvelles
vidéos est sortie ça c'est bien qu'il
est ennuyant de s'ennuyer
bonjour bonjour mais qui est nouveau
c'est pour vous je suis la cloche de
notification mais incroyable qu'est ce
que c'est c'est une clause qui vous
convient que la dernière vidéo
fabien olicard est sorti merci beaucoup
la cloche je vous en prie maintenant que
vous êtes abonné ou voyons ce qui se
passe dans la tête des milliardaires ces
personnes ont clairement rempli les deux
trois premiers étages de la pyramide de
maslow cette carabine même si elle est
controversée
elle représente un schéma simplifié des
besoins humains par paliers mais même
bachelot expliquer les limites de sa
théorie liées au manque de données mais
elles restent quand même intéressante à
observer avec les moyens qu'on les
milliardaires les besoins physiologiques
sont couverts très facilement le besoin
de sécurité également sauf s'ils
naviguent dans des zones à risques ça
peut arriver pour la plupart le besoin
d'appartenance et d'amour il est réglé
en grande partie du coup tout se joue
sur leur besoin d'estimé et de
reconnaissance et d'accomplissement de
soi et comme leur expérience ont appris
à leur cerveau que l'argent régler tout
bêtes passent souvent par des dépenses
un peu
le fondateur d'amazon jeff bezos a plus
que profiter de la crise sanitaire c'est
sûrement celui qui a le plus qui fait
qu'ils aient le corona à part pour mort
mais par rapport aux commandes
début juin 2020 amazon avait pris 30% de
plus depuis le début de l'année 2020 et
peser 1200 milliards guy tolar 6,1
milliards de secondes votre entend alors
amazon ou vos trente six mille ans on
fait une comparaison toujours pour que
le cerveau et puissent mieux appréhender
le truc toutes les sociétés du cac 40
réunis val 1700 milliards hockey soit 51
milan il est pas loin
il représente deux tiers du cac 40 les
loisirs de jeff bezos qui tape
littéralement dans les deux derniers
paliers de la pyramide de maslow en 2013
il a par exemple passé trois semaines
dans un sous marin pour récupérer les
propulseurs secondaire d'apollo 11
moi j'ai passé une semaine à grasse pour
visiter le musée du parfum voilà mais
lui sachent est ce qu'il ya de plus
précieux pour lui avec son argent du
temps par exemple il n'ya pas de réveil
à côté de lui chez amazon on sait que ça
sert à rien de prévoir une réunion le
matin où il doit être présente pas ce
qui sera pas là tous les coups en fait
jeff bezos s'il préfère le matin être en
famille en train de prendre le petit
déjeuner tranquille avec ses enfants et
sa femme
il a également un jet à 65 millions de
dollars qui dispose de la plus grande
autonomie au monde pour ce genre
d'appareil est juste une seule voiture
au garage
c'est vrai dépenses elles sont dans la
pierre il est propriétaire de cinq
maisons aux etats-unis dont une qui a
comme voisin peut-être chez lui la
famille obama
mais il ya des dépenses qui nous parlent
plus quand je dis nous c'est pour faire
référence à notre grille de lecture par
rapport à nos revenus communs l'ancien
dg de hubert par exemple il a préféré
s'offrir un an de congé pour faire un
voyage autour du monde et pas longtemps
derrière il a acheté un voilier qui a
coûté environ 70 millions de dollars
plus cher que des jets pour voyager dans
les îles polynésiennes
au revoir les bureaux et en même temps
vu les problèmes d'image qui avait
ibères en 2017 c'était pas plus mal il
valait mieux partir et donc bonjour la
polynésie l'un des deux fondateurs de
google lui préfère dépenser mille 600
euros par mois dans des cours de trapèze
privé alors il apprend ça dans un cirque
est très réputée à new york
meilleur engrais je trouve ça cool c'est
à dire que ils dépensent vraiment son
argent dans ce qu'il fait vibrer et je
trouve que là on se reconnaît nous aussi
dans ce genre de dépenses de temps si
j'avais de l'argent je me ferais qui
fait je ferai ce genre de choses je
crois qu'ils feraient salon du trapèze
et des billets en matelas
en tout cas c'est un autre délire que
son yacht le dragonfly qui coûte 70
millions d'euros
merci à bach market d'avoir sponsorisé
cette vidéo vous avez le lire dans la
description pour aller jeter un oeil sur
le site bonus non négligeable ce
partenariat va permettre de produire un
épisode de matière grise qui sortira ce
mois ci alors remercié à des
milliardaires et des achats délirant il
y en a plein dites moi dans les
commentaires si vous voulez un épisode 2
en gros ça ça dépend de vous des live
bien sûr du nombre de vues de la vidéo
pour voir si cette série vous motive ou
pas on pourra aussi creuser si vous
voulez sur l'aspect psychologique de
l'argent en fait sur sur notre cerveau
les effets que ça a commencé à le faire
réagir est ce que ça nous a plu ans ou
part n'oubliez pas de vous abonner ça
c'est gratuit activer la cloche pour ne
pas rater la prochaine vidéo ici je vous
mets une vidéo sur les étranges
habitudes de certains génies est ici une
vidéo sur les hypothèses expliquant qu
on n'a peut-être pas encore rencontré
les extraterrestres enfin pourquoi
comment on se retrouve en spectacle
bientôt également signé de paris nîmes
en salle de 5000 personnes je vais jouer
une version folle de mon spectacle
d'humour et de mentalisme voici
exactement les places qui restent
le lien est dans la description ainsi
que les dates de l'ultime tournée de ce
spectacle prenez soin de vous à très
bientôt
ciao